what's up guys welcome back to another
episode of trendy versus traditional
where we make two different versions of
the same dish for today's episode we
will both be making specifically we will
both be making omelets because oh it's
gonna be nonstop with you today
extremely excited cook that one episode
good luck thanks make make those eggs
real good enough what's up folks we're
gonna be making eggs today of all the
episodes we've done I think I have the
fewest ingredients on the table yes we
have butter we have eggs ham cheese
green pepper
ham and cheese is pretty standard
traditional omelet green bell peppers
find their way into omelets from time to
time there's a lot of really crazy
looking omelets out there the one I'll
be doing today is actually a tasty
recipe it's called super fluffy omelette
and it has over 13 million views if
that's not trendy I don't know what is
the cool thing about that omelette
though is that it was actually based on
a dish that's made in this pretty famous
French restaurant whose name I cannot
pronounce its specialty is that looks
like a really soft pillow egg it's like
a souffle omelette I'm gonna try and do
that today I have the tasty recipe which
I will base this off of but tweak it a
little bit to make it look a little more
like the og French omelette let's get
cracking here we go first we will be
starting with a beautiful green bell
pepper let's go ahead and do that I wish
that made a way cooler sound are you
gonna help me three two there we go
everyone needs to bear with me in this
time of puns Anka I know has ton locked
and loaded this is going to be an
extraordinarily big omelet we're gonna
use 5 eggs 2 eggs in here egg yolks and
egg whites three egg yolks in here and
separate three egg whites out if I whip
them up it might help
give it that like fluffy texture we're
talking about everyone was really
uncomfortable with the way I handled a
knife in previous videos you can trust
me no one is gonna get hurt
in our pepper cut up here I thought that
was dirt and I almost had a heart attack
I don't think we need a lot with
anything that you're putting into an
omelet the pieces should be relatively
small should have grabbed a bigger
cutting board but that's okay move this
into our Bowl here first egg in we go
boom second egg now we get to the split
in part I can't say I'm like a true
expert at this but this is high I can't
say I'm a true expert just doing my best
out here really leaning in on the puns
today it's gonna be an excellent time
last egg perf we're gonna go into ham
land similarly to the pepper we're just
gonna cut it up into little small pieces
I just rolled and cut this ham up like
you would herbs him does smell good
though just got a big whiff of ham ham
in olive oil in there's not gonna be any
filling in this omelet it's just gonna
be egg and egg and more eggs now that we
have eggs crack it's time for some egg
sir sighs we're gonna be doing a lot of
whipping I'm gonna start with the egg
yolk / egg mixture have this is back up
up here when case' I get a little too
tired but let's start off with the hands
now that the ham and my hands smell I
can give me once honestly that's it
we've done all of our prep work the next
step add Heat I'm just gonna be sauteing
wake up the reason I'm heating up the
ham is because you don't want to put
like cold ham and raw peppers into an
omelet you want to give them a head
start because the eggs are gonna the
eggs are gonna go like that just gonna
start whipping this up how'd I do this
for at least a five minutes I'm gonna be
here for a while guys I feel like Chris
is probably gonna get most of his done
while I'm still here beating this egg
pans nice and warm in go our ham and
peppers we're just looking to get a
little bit of color on the ham lose a
little bit of the crisp mists in the
peppers then we're just gonna take it
back out
getting real exhausted here I'm feeling
beat sorry guys I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry I'm unacceptable today
unacceptable I actually think we're
looking pretty good here they'll head
kill this there we go there we go
I'm gonna wipe this hand pan out and
then it's egg time oh but you can see
it's getting progressively fluffier
we're really just trying to beat some
air into these eggs you want it to be
lighter give it like a souffle
esque texture to play eggs and something
to happen we're just gonna cut up this
half quarter tablespoon of butter toss
that in turn the heat up and we're gonna
toss in all right I'm gonna do three
eggs cuz I'm a hungry boy the reason I
do eggs straight into the pan instead of
in a bowl it's just from like ease of
cleanup and I'm sorry if that's lazy of
me I'm just kind of whisking it all
together breaking the yolks up and I'm
also using a rubber spatula because then
you can start scraping the pan as the
eggs heat up they'll start forming
little curds low and slow is how I would
describe these eggs here alright guys
it's been about five minutes look at
boom it's super airy it's a bit foamy
it's fluffy feeling pretty good so now
I'm gonna set this aside now beat the
egg whites running out of muscle strain
so I'm gonna resort to the electric
mixer so we're starting to get a little
sticky cheer eggs are coming together
that's good you're kind of scrambling
them two-thirds of the way through in
that last third that's when you let it
sit as kind of this big crepe like form
[Music]
I'm just trying to get this to a stock
beat stage we're at the point where we
have some pretty like really loose
looking scrambled eggs
Oh quiet down stop it's getting foamy in
here see how this looks
Oh looking good just gonna combine the
two now gently fold the egg white soon
it's like a little cloud and then we're
just going to fold it in still super
airy trying to be gentle the whole
reason I'm like going like is because
because I'm trying to beat some air into
it so you don't want to waste all the
effort you put into it earlier this is
where we're gonna let the eggs kind of
let them just hang out let's get some
cheese going on Let Me In sprinkle in
some cheese Here I am a big ratio boy we
don't want up too much of a million
things and you bite into it we just get
a little bit of everything that's what
we want I'm not gonna use all of it just
gonna sprinkle that in putting it on 1/2
and then ideally as it's cooking on that
side we're gonna fold the other half of
the egg on to the filling side I'm just
going to pour this in that's a lot of
eggs you know a little pep pad it out
Sookie pretty good so far putting this
on a really low heat because I don't
want the bottom to overcook but I also
need to make sure that the top is cooked
cuz nobody wants to eat raw eggs huh I'm
gonna let just let us sit here for a
little bit right now it's just a waiting
game cooking takes a lot of patience
like 50% technique 50% patience while
I'm waiting I'm gonna cut up some chives
just a little bit of garnish right the
finish line again let's stay upright
let's finish strong that is pretty close
to setting up come here come here who
wants to see Chris wrestle and omelet
get on
this looks nice except for this little
extra tab here oh it's something caught
so big excuse me well I cover this up
there's smell very eggy in here this
dishes term is that you wanted to slide
cleanly off the pan and then fold it
like this perfect fold the center kind
of oozes out and it's just this glorious
egg pillow look at it it's jiggly you
can see that the edges are coming off a
little bit yes I'm just gonna lift this
up and slide it in like so same thing
here slide that butter right in the
butter is there for flavor it's also to
make it a little more Brown on the
bottom really okay I'm gonna take it off
the heat and let it sit for a little bit
because there's still some residual heat
your my thoughts on this omelet I feel
like this is like you got ready for
picture day feeling good you take the
picture and then you notice like one
piece of hair is just like going the
opposite direction that's how I feel
about this tiny little tear my
confidence Prix omelet fold 98% I think
right now I'm flying near like an 82
which is a B a B - we have a beautiful
red plate here as long as we get the
perfect fold it's very fragile you guys
okay wait push push how's that look
oh it's like oozing out that's kind of
what we wanted to do you can tell that
it's difficulty what do you call this
fluffy I'm talking really fast because
I'm really excited
seasoning time
[Music]
kena
oh I'm just so glad it turned out okay
so have a little bit Luth there so yeah
is it a beautiful omelette I don't think
so
but traditional home cooking it's not
always gonna be beautiful but it is
gonna be delicious
three two one oh no this is the guy she
tells you not to worry about this is sad
thank you time to invite someone in to
decide which egg omelette will reign
supreme this time we have our friend
Sabrina which really likes like so
Sabrina come on in okay first of all I'm
overwhelmed I'm staring in front of
these two really different but really
cool plate this plate right off the bat
catches my attention it looks like a
pancake and an omelette had a baby
you're getting all your breakfast in one
this one I feel like needs some baking a
Saturday morning kind of like home that
is what I'm going to very nice I'm ready
to just dig in we're Terra fried fried I
want another bite at us huh this is like
a cloud a souffle I really really love
the contrast of the foam with the actual
omelette itself I would order this you
know what I mean yes which one is reign
supreme even before we get to it
you made a beautiful lawn thank you you
too I gotta give it to the og I don't
know I gotta give it to the og it's a
humble omelet but the taste is just what
I think about on a Saturday morning I'm
old-school except I'll say I'm the most
excited to try this as well go ahead and
say it this omelet slaps I don't want my
win this was a good battle for something
so simple we left it all out there thank
you for bearing with us thank you for
bearing with our terrible egg funds um
we will see you next week
[Music]